Hi there, Shankar here. We're hot at work on a bunch of upcoming shows, so this week we thought we'd bring you a favorite from our archives. Our Creature Comforts show from last year. We hope you enjoyed the episode. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantantham. These days, we know how important it is for young children to feel loved. Parents are encouraged to sit with their kids, read to them, hug them, make them feel safe. But believe it or not, this wasn't always the case. It's so fascinating to look back on that period and think to yourself, how could you
大家好，我是香卡。我们最近正在紧锣密鼓地筹备一系列新节目，所以本周我们决定为大家重播档案库里的一期最爱：我们去年的“慰藉之物”节目。希望大家喜欢这期节目。这里是隐藏的大脑，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。如今，我们深知让幼儿感受到爱是多么重要。家长们被鼓励陪伴孩子、给他们读书、拥抱他们、让他们感到安全。但信不信由你，情况并非一直如此。回顾那个时期，心里真觉得不可思议，怎么会
get that so wrong? This is writer Deborah Blum. She's looked closely at what caused the revolution in psychology around how best to parent children. The early books told mothers not to hold their children at all if they could avoid it, that it would ruin the moral fiber of the child. We'll hear more about the effects of loving touch and its absence in a moment. We turn to one of our colleagues, Alison McCatum, for a personal story about the importance of affection, touch, and attachment. Alison's an editor at NPR, and she has a secret. I'm just going to come out and say it. I sleep with my blanket, my baby blanket. Here's what it looks like.
错得这么离谱？这是作家黛博拉·布鲁姆。她深入研究了引发心理学革命的原因，这场革命改变了人们对如何最好地抚养孩子的看法。早期的育儿书告诉母亲们，如果能避免，就千万不要抱孩子，因为这会摧毁孩子的道德品质。稍后我们将听到更多关于爱的抚触及其缺失的影响。我们请来了我们的同事爱丽森·麦卡达姆，来分享一个关于关怀、抚触和依恋重要性的个人故事。爱丽森是NPR的编辑，她有一个秘密。我索性就直说了吧。我和我的毛毯一起睡觉，我的婴儿毛毯。这是它的样子。
It's white woven cotton. It's a little threadbare. It is the softest thing in the world. Even on the hottest days, it feels cool. When I bury my nose in it, it smells like comfort. As a baby, apparently, I called it Baba. So, of course, I still call it Baba. Are you rolling your eyes yet?
它是白色织棉的。有点磨损得厉害。这是世界上最柔软的东西。即使在最热的日子里，它摸起来也很凉爽。当我把鼻子埋在它里面时，它闻起来就像安慰。据我小时候说，我管它叫“巴巴”。所以，当然，我现在还是叫它“巴巴”。你开始翻白眼了吗？
This is embarrassing to admit. And that's because I feel like society tells me I should have given up my blanket a long time ago. I did a quick Google search and I found all sorts of posts about when and how to win your child off a blanket. That's when, not if. Here's an example. One of those posts claims that psychologists have a wide range of opinions on when children should give up their blankets, but it says it is advisable to have overcome this hurdle
这承认起来怪不好意思的。那是因为我觉得社会在告诉我，我早就该戒掉这条毛毯了。我在谷歌上快速搜索了一下，发现各种关于何时以及如何帮孩子戒掉毛毯的帖子。那是“什么时候”，而不是“要不要”。这里有个例子。其中一篇帖子声称，心理学家对孩子应该在什么时候戒掉毛毯有着各种各样的看法，但它表示，最好能在
by the time the child is attending kindergarten. Well, I have not overcome my Baba, and I'm convinced I'm not alone. I know that some of you also crawl into bed and snuggle each night with a soft inanimate object. Do you hide it? Are you ashamed? Even my mom, my very affectionate mom,
孩子上幼儿园之前克服这个难关。好吧，我还没有克服我的“巴巴”，而且我确信我不是一个人。我知道你们当中也有人每晚爬上床，抱着一个柔软的无生命物体入睡。你把它藏起来了吗？你感到羞耻吗？甚至我妈妈，我那位非常慈爱的妈妈，
who gave me no shortage of hugs, even she is befuddled about my blanket. I asked her about it. I want to know what you think of the fact that I still sleep with my Baba. I think it's a little bizarre. Why is that? I think that's something you usually outgrow and give up as you become older and more secure and comfortable and you never did and I was pretty amazed when it went away to
她给了我数不清的拥抱，甚至连她也对我的毛毯感到困惑。我问过她这件事。我想知道你对我还抱着“巴巴”睡觉这件事有什么看法。我觉得有点不可思议。为什么呢？我觉得那是你随着年龄增长、变得更有安全感和更舒适时，通常会抛弃和放弃的东西，而你却没有。它陪你去了
college with you and I'm certainly amazed that you still sleep with it. Did you hear her words? Bizarre. You outgrow it, she says, as you become more secure, more comfortable. Ouch. Words like this, they creep inside you, and they park there.
大学，我当时就很震惊，现在听说你还抱着它睡，我当然更震惊了。你听到她的话了吗？不可思议。她说，随着你变得更有安全感、更舒适，你就会戒掉它。哎哟。这样的话语，它们会潜入你的内心，并在那里扎根。
If you're wondering how old I am, the answer is, I turn 40 this year. I'm married, I have a child, and I've thought about this question a lot. Is my Baba a sign that I'm a failed adult? Insecure, immature? One day I got this email. It was from my brother, he lives in Chicago, and he was hanging out with a friend of his, who also sleeps with a blanket. And he told me, she seems really tough, but she has a heart of gold.
如果你在想我多大了，答案是，我今年40岁了。我结婚了，有一个孩子，我经常思考这个问题。“巴巴”是我成为一个失败成人的标志吗？我不够安全感、不成熟吗？有一天我收到了这样一封电子邮件。是我哥哥发来的，他住在芝加哥，当时他和他的一个朋友在一起，那个朋友也抱着毛毯睡觉。他告诉我，她看起来真的很坚强，但她有一颗金子般的心。
I thought, why don't I meet this woman? And that led me to a dark rock club in Chicago, it's called the Empty Bottle. It was the beginning of the night a band was sound checking. It would be 450 please. It's a cash on me by. And that's Bartender Aaron Page. I would say that I'm a pretty classic punk rack venue bartender. Give you a shot in your beer and then you go away and have a good time.
我想，我为什么不认识一下这位女士呢？这把我带到了芝加哥的一家黑暗摇滚俱乐部，名叫“空瓶子”。那是夜幕降临的时候，一支乐队正在试音。请付450。这里只收现金。那位是酒保亚伦·佩吉。我会说我是一个相当经典的朋克摇滚场所调酒师。给你倒上一杯酒和啤酒，然后你就可以走开，好好享受时光了。
Aaron Page, black haired, tattoos, upper arms, she sleeps with her baby blanket. I asked Aaron if spending evenings in a loud bar makes her long for a blanket. Oh yeah, all the time, every night. Every night on my life, I go home and I get in my bed and I put the blanket on my head or under my head usually it's the best. Here's what really strikes me about Erin. She feels none of the shame I feel about being a full grown adult with a blanket. She and I
亚伦·佩吉，黑头发，上臂有纹身，她抱着她的婴儿毛毯睡觉。我问亚伦，在喧闹的酒吧度过夜晚是否会让她渴望一条毛毯。哦，是的，一直都是，每天晚上。我生活中的每个夜晚，我回家上床睡觉，把毛毯盖在头上或垫在头底下，通常这是最棒的。真正让我对亚伦印象深刻的是：对于一个成年人还带着毛毯这件事，她没有感到一丝一毫我所感受到的羞耻。她和我
talked about that somewhere quieter at her apartment. And how long have you lived? When she's not bartending, Erin plays in a punk rock band and she designs poster art. Her walls are decorated with that art, and it has a distinctive goth style. Like, this is what I'm working on right now.
在公寓里一个安静的地方聊了聊。你住在这里多久了？不当调酒师时，亚伦会在一支朋克乐队里演奏，她还设计海报艺术。她的墙上挂满了这种艺术品，带有鲜明的哥特风格。就像，这是我目前正在创作的作品。
There's the skull and some the devil and some eyeballs and this woman and a trans. Erin told me her art is an expression of a child's imagination. And her blankie is kind of the same thing. It's a way of keeping the good feelings of childhood alive. Can we, can we go get your blanket? We have it. Okay, I got it out because I knew that you had one to see it. Erin's blanket is a faded yellow quilt. You can see the outlines of stitched on teddy bears
那里有头骨、一些恶魔、一些眼球、这个女人和一个传送带。亚伦告诉我，她的艺术是儿童想象力的表达。她的毛毯也差不多是这样。这是让童年的美好感觉保持活力的一种方式。我们能，我们能去拿你的毛毯吗？我们有它。好的，我把它拿出来了，因为我知道你有一条，想看看。亚伦的毛毯是一条褪色的黄色被子。你可以看到缝在上面但
that fell off a long time ago. She likes to wrap it over her head like a huge scarf. And let me tell you the contrast is striking between her tattooed arms and those faded teddy bears. Before I left Erin's apartment I couldn't help but have a little blanky convention. Oh my gosh, yours is even more thread bears than mine. That's awesome. Mine is called Baba.
很久以前掉落的泰迪熊的轮廓。她喜欢把它像一条巨大的围巾一样裹在头上。让我告诉你，她纹身的胳膊和那些褪色的泰迪熊形成了鲜明的对比。离开亚伦的公寓前，我不禁办了个小型毛毯交流会。哦天哪，你的比我的磨损得还要厉害。太棒了。我的叫“巴巴”。
Baba. It's called Baba. It's so soft. It is really soft, isn't it? It is, it's like a kind of... If you're laughing at us, that's fine. But maybe you're the weird one. I think it's weird that you wouldn't want to hold on to something from childhood that
“巴巴”。它叫“巴巴”。它太软了。真的很软，不是吗？是的，它有点像……如果你在笑话我们，那没关系。但也许你才是那个奇怪的人。我觉得奇怪的是，你竟然不想抓住童年时的某样东西，
was a prized possession. There's one final issue about my Baba that I should address, or let's say one final person. I'm Simon Rodberg, I'm the husband of Allison MacAdam, who still loves her Baba. And my husband. Every night I climb into bed with Simon and with Baba. So what does he think of that?
那可是件珍贵的物品。关于我的“巴巴”，还有一个最后的问题我应该谈谈，或者说最后一个人。我是西蒙·罗德伯格，我是爱丽森·麦卡达姆的丈夫，她依然深爱着她的“巴巴”。还有我的丈夫。每天晚上，我都和西蒙还有“巴巴”一起钻进被窝。那么他是怎么想的呢？
I suppose I thought that I might replace Baba at some point, that you never buried somebody before. Maybe Baba was just a placeholder till your husband got there. And I'm not quite sure what I realized. That in fact, I would be sure I would be sharing the bed with Baba, rather than replacing Baba and your affections.
我想我曾以为在某个时候我会取代“巴巴”，你从来没有把谁埋葬过。也许“巴巴”只是一个暂时的替代品，直到你丈夫出现。我不大确定我意识到了什么。事实上，我确信我会和“巴巴”一起分享这张床，而不是在你的爱中取代“巴巴”。
And I think, no, I don't think I've minded, to be honest. I think, I love you, I love your Baba. That's just the way our marriage works. By the way, when I'm not in bed, Simon reaches over to my side of the bed, grabs Baba and snuggles with it himself. Baba reminds me of you. There's this thing that you've loved all your life.
而且我觉得，不，说实话，我不介意。我想，我爱你的芭芭，我爱你。我们的婚姻就是这样运作的。顺便说一句，当我不在床上时，西蒙会把手伸到我这边的床，抓起芭芭，自己抱着它入睡。芭芭让我想起了你。这是你一辈子都深爱的东西。
And I don't know particularly, I don't have a very good sense of smell. I don't know that it smells like you. It doesn't feel like you, but there's you in it. And so it's nice when I don't actually have you to be able to, you know, put my arms around something that you love. So I hope all the grown-ups out there who still sleep with their blankets have partners who are as Bob-Bob positive as mine.
而且我不太清楚，我的嗅觉其实不太灵敏。我不知道它闻起来是不是像你。它感觉不像你，但里面有你的影子。所以，当我身边没有你时，能够去拥抱你所爱的东西，你知道的，这种感觉真好。所以我希望外面所有那些仍然抱着毯子睡觉的成年人，都有像我一样对“芭芭”持积极态度的伴侣。
NPR's Addison McCatum. When we come back, we'll hear about the pioneering scientist who first showed how cuddling with a blanket or loved one was not only not bad for us. It was absolutely essential to physical and mental well-being. These little baby monkeys would hold on to the cloth. They didn't want to let go. They were cuddling it. It made them feel safe in a way.
美国国家公共电台的艾迪生·麦卡特姆。节目稍后回来，我们将为您讲述这位开创性科学家的故事，他首次证明了与毛毯或所爱之人依偎不仅无害，而且对身心健康绝对至关重要。这些小猴子会紧紧抓住布料不放。它们舍不得放手。它们在依偎着它。这在某种程度上让它们感到安全。
Stay with us. MUSIC When I first taught Addison McCatum's story about her comfort blanket, I remembered a wonderful book by the writer Debra Blum. It explored the powerful role that touch plays in our lives. Love at Goon Park tells the story of psychologist Harry Harlow and his groundbreaking experiments about attachment and affection. Debra, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. It's great to be here. You describe in your book something that seems very surprising to me,
请继续收听。音乐 当我最初讲述艾迪生·麦卡特姆关于她安抚毛毯的故事时，我想起了作家黛布拉·布鲁姆的一本精彩的书。它探讨了触觉在我们生活中发挥的强大作用。《爱在古恩公园》讲述了心理学家哈里·哈洛以及他关于依恋和情感的开创性实验的故事。黛布拉，欢迎来到“隐藏大脑”。谢谢你。很高兴来到这里。你在书中描述了一件让我感到非常惊讶的事情，
which is that back in the 1950s, there were many prominent behavioral experts who believed that touch was a problem, that children in particular shouldn't be caressed, excessively, shouldn't be held and cuddled excessively. Talk to me about that moment and where these experts were coming from.
那就是早在20世纪50年代，有许多著名的行为主义专家认为触觉是个问题，尤其是儿童不应该受到过度的抚摸，不应该被过多地抱在怀里和依偎。请跟我谈谈那个时刻，以及这些专家当时的想法是从何而来的。
It's so fascinating to look back on that period and think to yourself, how could you get that so wrong? But it grew out of a kind of behaviorist idea that that kind of, you know, a solid foundation of affection is scientists, including ones I wrote about, would describe it. Didn't really matter. The mother was there as a food source, kept the kid warm, answered its immediate physical needs, but the early books told mothers not to hold their children at all if they could avoid it, that it would ruin the moral fiber of the child.
回首那个时期，心里想：怎么会错得这么离谱？这真是太迷人了。但这源于一种行为主义的观点，即正如我写过的一些科学家所描述的那样，那种坚实的情感基础其实并不重要。母亲存在于那里是为了提供食物，保持孩子的温暖，满足其直接的身体需求，但早期的书籍告诫母亲们，如果可以避免，就根本不要抱自己的孩子，因为这会毁掉孩子的道德品质。
The child would become weak, the child would become dependent, the child would never become an independent human being. So you spent a lot of time in the book talking about a very interesting and controversial figure who in some ways set the stage to overturn many of these ideas. So tell me about Harry Harlow, who he was, and how he came to his ideas. Yeah, Harry Harlow was a really fascinating, complicated, brilliant, difficult subject to write about. He's the center of Love at Goon Park, and I often described him as a charismatic, chain-smoking, poetry-writing, alcoholic, flandering, workaholic.
孩子会变得软弱，孩子会变得依赖，孩子将永远无法成为一个独立的人。所以在书中，你花了大量时间谈论一个非常有趣且备受争议的人物，他在某种程度上为推翻这些观点奠定了基础。那么，请告诉我哈里·哈洛是谁，以及他是如何萌生这些想法的。是的，哈里·哈洛是一个非常迷人、复杂、才华横溢且难以撰写的传记对象。他是《爱在古恩公园》的核心人物，我经常形容他是一个富有领袖魅力、烟不离手、会写诗、酗酒、风流成性且工作狂的人。
Right, you can go on and on. And so the best and worst person to write about, because he inhabits your house while you're writing the book and he's not easy company. But one of the things that made him such a fascinating and eventually controversial subject was that he was intellectually fearless. He was one of the earlier developers of a primate model, right?
没错，你可以说个没完。所以他是最适合也是最难下笔的传记人物，因为当你写这本书时，他就占据了你的生活，而且他可不是个好相处的人。但让他成为如此迷人且最终备受争议的人物的原因之一，在于他在学术上无所畏惧。他是灵长类动物模型较早的开发者之一，对吧？
We tend to take that for granted now, but in fact, he went to the University of Wisconsin in the 1930s and built an early primate colony there from scratch, bringing in a small number of monkeys, mostly Reese's Maccaxx, which are very smart, very social monkeys from Southeast Asia. And they were following kind of the human model. They kept their baby monkeys separate from the mothers. They kept them in sterile conditions so that there wasn't an infection. They were singly housed. They would give them though a sterile diaper as kind of batting and a soft cloth to sleep in in their tiny sterile cage when they would go to take out the cloth and put in another clean one. These
我们现在往往认为这是理所当然的，但事实上，他在20世纪30年代前往威斯康星大学，从零开始在那里建立了一个早期的灵长类动物繁育基地，引入了少量的猴子，主要是恒河猴。这是一种来自东南亚的非常聪明、非常具社交性的猴子。他们当时遵循的是人类的模式。他们将猴宝宝与母亲分开饲养。为了防止感染，他们将猴宝宝保存在无菌环境中。它们是单笼饲养的。不过，当猴宝宝们待在狭小无菌的笼子里时，他们会给它们一块无菌尿布作为填充物，以及一块柔软的毛毯供其睡眠。当他们去拿走毛毯换上另一块干净的毛毯时，这些
little baby monkeys would hold on to the cloth. They didn't want to let go. They were cuddling it. They almost had an emotional attachment to it in ways that surprised all of the scientists. And there was nothing, absolutely nothing in the landscape of psychology that would have predicted this because touch didn't matter and Emotions were not part of early childhood development and so hurl a looked at this and he said What does this mean and so he and a few of his very smart graduate students? And so he and a few of his very smart graduate students sat down and they designed a program just to look at the idea that touch actually mattered. Tell me about the experiments that he conducted. So what they did is really very brilliant.
猴宝宝就会紧紧抓住毛毯不放。它们不肯放手。它们依偎着它。它们甚至对它产生了某种情感依恋，这种程度让所有的科学家都感到惊讶。在心理学的领域里，没有任何东西（绝对没有任何东西）能够预见到这一点，因为触觉无关紧要，情绪也不是早期儿童发育的一部分。因此，哈洛看到这一幕便开始思考：这意味着什么？于是，他和几位非常聪明的研究生坐在一起，设计了一个项目，专门来研究触觉其实至关重要的观点。跟我讲讲他所做的实验。所以他们所做的事情实际上非常绝妙。
They built two versions of a mother, what you might call a surrogate or a robot mother, one of them is made of wire and one of them has a wire body but has a lovely, cuddly, thick cloth padding. It's a cuddly version of the wire mother. Both of them have faces, right? They put on faces that was more for the researchers than for the monkeys. And both of them are warm. They put light bulbs in both of them. So it would simulate the warmth of a mother's body. And then what they would do is they would put wire mom and cloth mom in the same enclosure with baby monkeys. And they would do one other thing. Wire mom fed the baby monkeys, right? There was a bottle with milk.
他们制造了两个版本的母亲，你可以称之为代孕母亲或机器人母亲。其中一个由铁丝制成，另一个拥有铁丝身体，但外面包裹着一层厚实、舒适、可爱的布料填充物。这是铁丝母亲的依偎版。它们都有脸，对吧？它们装上了脸，这主要是为了研究人员而不是为了猴子。而且它们都是温暖的。他们在两者的内部都放置了灯泡，从而模拟母亲身体的温暖。接着，他们会把铁丝妈妈和布料妈妈放进同一个围栏里，和猴宝宝待在一起。他们还做了另一件事。铁丝妈妈喂养猴宝宝，对吧？那里放着一个装有奶的奶瓶。
The wire mother held the bottle. Cloth mother her only virtue was that she was warm and cuddly. What they found there was that the baby monkeys, they lived on the cloth mother. They cuddled and held on, and when they got hungry, they had these cloth mothers, if I could create this picture in your mind, they would have these two mothers side by side. These little baby monkeys still holding on to their warm cuddly cloth mom will lean over,
铁丝母亲拿着奶瓶。布料母亲唯一的优点就是她温暖且惹人怜爱。他们发现，猴宝宝们就生活在布料母亲身上。它们依偎并紧紧抓着不放。当它们饿了的时候，它们身边有这些布料母亲——如果我能在你脑海中勾勒出这个画面，它们会让这两个母亲并排站在一起。这些小猴宝宝依然紧紧抓着温暖可爱的布料妈妈不放，同时把身体向前倾斜，
their hat tips over just far enough that they can get to the milk, but they're not going to let go of what Harlow eventually called contact comfort. We need that kind of loving touch as much as we need to be fed. Obviously we need to be fed, but in terms of the way we grow up as a solid, well-rounded, given, caring-connected person, the touch is more important. So when Harlow did these experiments and he found that the monkeys really needed touch in order to thrive, what was the reception to these ideas when he announced it to the world? Completely hostile in the beginning. He gave a speech. It's still one of my favorite speeches ever in the history of science called The Nature of Love, in which
它们的头刚好探得足够远，能够够到奶吃，但它们绝不会放开哈洛后来称之为“接触安慰”的东西。我们需要那种充满爱意的触觉，就像我们需要食物一样。显然我们需要食物，但就我们成长为一个坚定、全面发展、懂得关爱且与他人有连接的人而言，触觉更为重要。所以，当哈洛做了这些实验，并发现猴子为了繁衍生息确实需要触觉时，当他向世界公布这些想法时，各方对此有何反应？起初是完全的敌意。他发表了一演讲。这仍然是科学史上我最喜欢的演讲之一，名为《爱的本质》，在这场演讲中，
to show you what an interesting guy he was, it's full of dog rule poetry. I mean, you're not going to see this kind very often. But in which he basically got in the face of the scientific community and said, you've blown it. You've been blowing it. He said, a literature gets this better than us. And poets get this better than us. And we need for psychology to catch up with basic commons and see and he said and I think this
为了向你展示他是一个多么有趣的人，演讲中充满了打油诗。我的意思是，你不会经常看到这种类型的演讲。但他基本上是在科学界面前直言不讳地说：“你们搞砸了。你们一直都在搞砸。”他说，文学作品比我们更能理解这一点。诗人也比我们更能理解这一点。我们需要让心理学赶上基本的常识，并且他说，而且我认为这
is correct there's a lot of parents who get this they're not listening to you because you have gotten this wrong and the nature of love is about touch and comfort and my favorite part of the Herala message, the nature of love is every day. I'm there for you, which is what touch says. He made that argument. It was completely rejected by the still very powerful behaviorist community. But if you look at what happens over the next decade or so, he keeps pushing
是正确的，有很多父母都懂这一点。他们不听你们的，因为你们弄错了。爱的本质关乎触觉和安慰。而哈洛演讲中我最喜欢的部分是：爱的本质就是每一天。我都在你身边，这就是触觉所传达的信息。他提出了这个观点。这个观点遭到了当时仍然极其强大的行为主义者群体的彻底拒绝。但是，如果你看看接下来十年左右发生的事情，他一直在坚持推动
it, his graduate students go out and take that message with them and they continue to push it. And about the same time, or not too much later, you see child psychologists come up and pick it up. So it wasn't that rocket went off and fireworks dazzled in the sky when he gave the speech, but it was that a few people heard him and it was that he didn't give up. You know, I reached out to you, Deborah, in the first place when I heard Alison McCatum's story about her security blanket. One of the things that struck me when I first heard Alison's story is that at some level, she was embarrassed by the fact that she still loved this childhood blanket that she derived so much comfort from the blanket. And really as I listen to her and
它，他的研究生们走出去，将这个信息带给他人，并继续推动它。大约在同一时期，或者不久之后，你看到儿童心理学家们开始接受并采纳它。所以，当他发表这篇演讲时，并没有像火箭升空、烟花在空中绽放那样轰动，而是有一些人听进去了，而且他没有放弃。你知道的，黛布拉，最初当我听到艾迪生·麦卡特姆讲述她关于安全毯的故事时，我联系了你。当我第一次听到艾迪生的故事时，让我震惊的一点是，在某种程度上，她为自己依然深爱着这个童年时期的毛毯、从毛毯中获得如此多的慰藉而感到尴尬。事实上，当我听她讲述并
I remember your book, the thing that really popped in my head was, you know, Allison is just profoundly normal. The idea that you would actually have things in your life that you would want to cuddle with or even things that you have a ritual of cuddling with before you go to sleep at night. These are hardly things to be ashamed about. I completely agree. And I think if people really think about it, you know, you have these moments or objects or memories. We have these points in our life that give us comfort. And sometimes it's something soft and cuddly.
回想起你的书时，我脑海中突然浮现出的想法是：你知道的，艾迪生其实非常正常。你生活中确实会有一些想要去依偎的东西，甚至在夜间入睡前有着依偎它们的仪式感，这些想法根本没什么好羞耻的。我完全同意。我认为，如果人们真的去思考它，你知道的，你的生活中会有这些时刻、物体或记忆。我们生命中都有这些能给我们带来安慰的点滴。有时，它就是某种柔软而又令人依偎的东西。
I actually, I have my son's tiny t-shirt and he's almost 27 years old, right? So he was wearing this more than two decades ago. And when I pick up that shirt, it makes me happy. I think, you know, if we actually sit and examine our own life, that's completely normal. These more things that we can touch that remind us of who we are and what we're connected to that give us comfort throughout our lives. And frankly, I like that about us.
事实上，我有我儿子的一件小T恤，他现在快27岁了，对吧？所以他二十多年前就穿过这件衣服了。当我拿起这件衬衫时，它让我感到快乐。我想，你知道的，如果我们真正坐下来审视自己的生活，这完全是正常的。这些我们可以触摸的物品，提醒着我们自己是谁、我们与什么相连，它们在我们的整个生命中给予我们安慰。坦白说，我很喜欢我们身上这一点。
I like that about us too. We should all remember to hug more. I wish we could end today's episode right here on the sweet note. But there's more to say. There's more to Harry Harlow's story, and there's more to the role of touch in our lives. Yes, cuddling is important and childhood blankies ought to be part of all our lives. But there are deeper lessons, and we felt it wouldn't be honest if we didn't go there. Harry Harlow's experiments into the importance of touch took a dark turn after a personal tragedy in his life.
我也很喜欢我们身上这一点。我们都应该记住要多给彼此一个拥抱。我希望我们能在今天这个温馨的音符上结束这期节目。但还有更多话要说。哈里·哈洛的故事还有更多内容，触觉在我们生活中的作用也远不止于此。是的，依偎很重要，童年的毛毯也理应成为我们所有人生活的一部分。但还有更深层的教训，我们觉得如果不去探讨这些，就显得不够诚实。在经历了一场个人悲剧之后，哈里·哈洛关于触觉重要性的实验走向了黑暗的转变。
He started to explore not just the nature of love, but its opposite, isolation, neglect, abuse. Those experiments permanently tarnished his reputation. It's important to talk about them not just because it provides a more complete account of his life, but because the experiments have profound implications for social policy today. What I find so disturbing about Harry Harlow is that someone who spends so much time thinking about love and the importance of love also came up with experiments, especially in his later years, that could only be described as disturbing. And almost torturous, right?
他开始探索的不仅仅是爱的本质，还有它的对立面：孤立、忽视、虐待。这些实验永远玷污了他的声誉。谈论它们很重要，不仅是因为这能提供对他一生的更完整描述，还因为这些实验对当今的社会政策有着深远的影响。我对哈里·哈洛感到最不安的是，一个花那么多时间思考爱和爱的重要性的人，也设计出了各种实验，尤其是在他晚年时期，这些实验只能被形容为令人不安。几乎可以说是折磨性的，对吧？
They're horribly haunting experiments, and he's probably most famous in the animal rights community of being one of, you know, the most horrible of all primate researchers of the 20th century for the depression experiments in which he was looking at depression is sort of a mental isolation. Can you recover from that? And to do that, he actually built different devices that would isolate monkeys from everything,
这确实是非常挥之不去的实验，在动物保护界，他可能是20世纪名声最臭的灵长类动物研究人员之一，因为他做了抑郁实验，他当时在研究抑郁症作为一种精神隔离的形式。你能从那种状态中恢复过来吗？为了做到这一点，他实际上建造了不同的设备，将猴子与一切隔离开来，
from their families, from the rest of the community, from any kind of touch, including human touch, and he would leave them there, and then he would bring them out and see if they could recover in any meaningful way. Some of them dead, some of them were permanently damaged by the isolation. And in a very harlow way,
与它们的家人隔离，与社区的其余部分隔离，与包括人类触觉在内的任何触觉隔离，他把它们留在那里，然后把它们放出来，看看它们是否能以任何有意义的方式恢复。其中一些死去了，一些由于隔离而受到了永久性的伤害。用一种非常哈洛式的风格，
he described probably the most infamous of those devices as the pit of despair, which was essentially an inverted pyramid. The baby monkey went into the point of the triangle. It opened up, wide armed with a mesh on top, so the little animal couldn't get bad out, couldn't be touched. Food and water were supplied, but it was alone in this point.
他把其中最臭名昭著的设备描述为“绝望之坑”，它本质上是一个倒立的金字塔。小猴子进入了三角形的尖端。它顶部开口很大，上面有网眼，所以小动物无法爬出来，也无法被触摸。提供食物和水，但它独自在这个尖端。
It was terrible. I mean, we're talking about a social species, and one that thrives in comfort of touch, and there was none of that. And there are hard to read and hard to understand, given what he knew about those animals, right? And I don't defend them. And I just can't. And I don't think many of the, you know, psychology students who work with them, they don't defend them either.
这太可怕了。我的意思是，我们谈论的是一个社会性物种，一个在触觉的安慰中茁壮成长的物种，而这一切全都没有了。鉴于他对这些动物的了解，这些实验很难阅读，也很难理解，对吧？我不为它们辩护。我只是做不到。而且我认为，许多与他共事的心理学学生，他们也不为之辩护。
They made a point, but I'm not sure that point needed to be made the way he made it. He did other experiments that are dark, that raised some more complicated issues, and the one I wanted to describe came earlier, in which you're looking at contact comfort. One of the things they discovered about cloth mom, which was really interesting in thinking about development, is that she never rejected, right? As long as the baby monkey wanted to be in that sort of warm, fuzzy cloth embrace, she was there. And there are plenty of human beings
他们证明了一个观点，但我不太确定这个观点是否需要通过他那种方式来证明。他还做过其他一些黑暗的实验，引发了一些更复杂的问题，我想描述的那个实验较早，当时你在研究接触安慰。关于布妈妈，他们发现了一件非常有趣的事情，那就是她从不拒绝，对吧？只要小猴子想沉浸在那类温暖、毛茸茸的布料拥抱中，她就在那里。而且有很多人类
who are less than ideal parents in many ways. Can we study that? And they built a series of what he called evil mothers and they were evil. They built a cloth mother and in the cloth was embedded blunt spikes. And so when the baby monkey comes and clings, the spikes will shoot out and push it off. They predicted all the monkeys would end up psychotic. They actually got psychosis with those isolation experiments. But in this case, what happened was that the baby monkeys didn't become psychotic.
在很多方面都不是理想的父母。我们能研究这个吗？于是他们建造了一系列他所谓的“邪恶母亲”，它们确实很邪恶。他们建造了一个布妈妈，布里面嵌入了钝刺。因此，当小猴子走过去依偎时，尖刺会弹出来把它推开。他们预测所有猴子最终都会精神失常。他们在那些隔离实验中确实导致了精神失常。但在这种情况下，发生的情况是小猴子并没有精神失常。
They came back and tried to fix the relationship. And as soon as the spikes retracted, they'd come back and they'd try to make her love them. And they'd hold on and they'd coup and they'd cling and they'd flirt and they'd do everything babies do. Monkey babies and human babies. Love me, right? Let me do all of these things that will make you
它们回来了，试图修复这段关系。一旦尖刺缩回去，它们就会回来，试图让她爱它们。它们会抓紧，会发出咕咕声，会依偎，会撒娇，会做小宝宝们做的一切事情。小猴子和人类宝宝。爱我，对吧？让我做所有这些事情，让你
want to be with me. And they would abandon all their other relationships to fix this. Right? Just give up, you know, wouldn't hang out with their friends. They needed to fix that first fundamental relationship. It's heartbreaking, right? It's heartbreaking to think about it for these little animals and for children. And then one of the things that struck me the most when I went out, I was booktouring after Love at Goon Park came out. And I gave a talk and I described these experiments.
想要和我在一起。它们会放弃所有其他关系来修复这一点。对吧？就这样放弃，你知道的，不再和朋友闲逛。它们需要修复那个最初的基础关系。这太让人心碎了，对吧？为这些小动物和孩子们感到心碎，这让人感到心碎。然后，当我出去时，最让我震惊的一件事是，在《爱在古恩公园》出版后，我正在进行图书巡回宣传。我做了一场演讲，描述了这些实验。
And this woman came up afterwards and she was a nurse in a unit at the hospital there that treated the adult survivors of neglect and abuse. And she said to me, well, you're describing our patients, right? And they're 30 or 40 or 50 or older. You're as old and they're still trying to fix that first relationship. I can see echoes also what sort of the debates we've had over, for example, solitary confinement and the effects of solitary confinement on human beings and what happens to them. Harry Harlow is not the only one who's done work on this, of course, but it feels again
随后有个女人走过来，她是当地一家医院病房的护士，那里治疗遭受忽视和虐待的成年幸存者。她对我说，嗯，你描述的是我们的病人，对吧？他们30岁、40岁、50岁或更大。你一样大，而他们仍然在试图修复最初的那段关系。我也能从中听到一些回响，比如我们围绕例如单独监禁以及单独监禁对人类的影响及其后果所进行的辩论。当然，哈洛并不是唯一一个在这方面做过工作的人，但感觉依然
that they're just such strong echoes with child abuse and solitary confinement and what happens in human beings when they're deprived of touch long, long, long after they've stopped being children. We've done these experiments. We don't have to do them again. We should never do them again, but we should listen to them because they do tell us profound things about solitary confinement. They should have been listened to a lot more about touch, about the importance of what I
存在着如此强烈的情感回响：关于虐待儿童和单独监禁，以及当人类在不再是儿童很久很久很久之后被剥夺触觉时会发生什么。我们已经做过这些实验了。我们不必再做一次。我们绝不应该再做一次，但我们应该倾听它们的意见，因为它们确实告诉了我们关于单独监禁的深刻道理。人们本该多听听他们关于触觉的意见，关于我
think of as, you know, kitchen love, love is an everyday quality. They still have an important message and you can love or hate Harry Harlow and people do both, right? But some of the messages, some of the ideas, some of the things that he tried to teach still matter. Deborah Blum is the Pulitzer Prize-winning author of Love at Goon Park. This week's show was produced by Maggie Panman and Jenny Schmidt, our staff includes Tara Boyle, Renee Clark, Raina Cohen and Chloe Conley. Our unsung hero this week is Mary Glendonning. Mary is the Deputy Chief of Research, Archives and Data Strategy here at NPR.
认为的那些……厨房之爱，爱是一种日常品质的重要性。他们仍然传达着重要的信息，你可以爱哈洛也可以恨哈洛，人们两种态度都有，对吧？但他的一些信息、一些理念、他试图教给我们的某些东西依然重要。黛博拉·布鲁姆是普利策奖得主、《爱在古恩公园》的作者。本周的节目由玛吉·潘曼和珍妮·施密特制作，我们的员工包括塔拉·博伊尔、蕾妮·克拉克、雷娜·科恩和克洛伊·康利。我们本周的无名英雄是玛丽·格伦多宁。玛丽是NPR研究、档案馆和数据战略副总监。
She is a person we turn to when we are stumped with a fact check on need help tracking down a long-lost audio clip or a hard-to-find interview. When we hit a wall with our research, we know that Mary will have an idea we haven't tried yet. Thanks Mary for all your help. Our show is stronger because of you. If you like hidden brain, you can help others find us by reviewing the show on iTunes. And if you're a teacher, be sure to check out our new study guides and fill out the survey letting us know what you think. You can find them at npr.org slash hidden brain. Just click on the tab that says education.
当我们被事实核查难住、需要帮助寻找失落已久的音频剪辑或难以找到的采访时，她就是我们要求助的人。当我们的研究陷入僵局时，我们知道玛丽会有一个我们还没有尝试过的想法。谢谢你，玛丽，感谢你所有的帮助。因为有你，我们的节目才更强大。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，你可以通过在iTunes上对节目进行评价来帮助其他人找到我们。如果你是一位老师，请务必查看我们的新学习指南，并填写调查问卷让我们知道你的想法。你可以在 npr.org 上的 hidden brain 找到它们。只需点击标有“教育”的标签。
I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。